modernizing traditional workflows
requires building cloud-first solutions
join us in historic downtown Austin
Texas as we talk to sadhus systems about
their cloud architecture and how they've
built atom so let's talk about atom
what does the architecture look like for
atom atoms architectures very robust
everything is built on Google cloud
platform we're leveraging kubernetes
engine for all of the different micro
services and there's a various array of
portals with an atom each portal may
have three or four various types of
micro services that back that
infrastructure it gives us the
flexibility of specifying the right tool
for the job which means we can say hey
this data is very relational very
specific in the way that it's laid out
we can back that with a cloud sequel
database whereas other data with an atom
is very non relational and dynamic based
on whoever the client may be in what
asset class they have so we can specify
that database to be a no sequel solution
most of them I'm going to be Atlas
specifically we have dataflow jobs where
we pull data in from all various deities
that we work with or different agencies
and they have data today in there ESRI
server or their ArcGIS server that we
pull from and then real-time display
with an atom and so that whole
experience is more or less seamless
through Google cloud platform so what
other tools inside of Google Cloud are
using so we use almost the full gamut
specifically around logging tracing a
lot towards developer productivity so
that we can be agile enough to respond
to the demands of the customers so we're
pushing code very regularly on a weekly
almost bi-weekly basis and for us to be
able to do that we need the platform to
do a lot of the heavy lifting in terms
of automation in terms of security best
practices so that the command center
threat detection you name it we're
leveraging the tools to help boost
developer productivity and that's that's
our big win on Adam is enabling
everybody on the team to be comfortable
with the platform and proficient at
provisioning these services yeah you
talked a little bit about kubernetes
being kind of the cornerstone of a lot
of this architecture why kubernetes so
kubernetes gives us the availability to
scale based on demand both horizontally
and vertically so we're not running
hundreds of hundreds of VMs at ten
percent utilization we're able to
utilize our resources very effectively
which ties directly into the pricing
models that we offer these deities we
can be very competitive because we are
optimizing our consumption and so where
that plays a big role is we have periods
of time throughout the day where we have
a high amount of traffic and load
specifically around our download and
offline consumption so in the
traditional sense somebody will will go
out and perform a bridge inspection now
before they go out they realize hey I'm
not gonna have self connectivity in this
in this location so what they do is they
download everything that they need to do
on the job site and then they work fully
offline so when they regain connectivity
obviously all of those updates come back
to that application we have a robust
pipeline with pub/sub and and what have
you but the actual services themselves
need to scale very rapidly to that
demand because you can imagine the end
of the days when all the inspectors come
back to their hotel rooms they regain
connectivity and it's eight plus hours
worth of work now getting pushed over to
our application so the ability to
respond to that demand has been very
critical and that's that's the primary
reason why we use whoo kubernetes engine
for
so you mentioned developer productivity
earlier as Google cloud helped you with
making sure that your developers are
more productive while working on Adam
yes a developer productivity is
drastically increased since we've
adopted Google cloud platform and and
really started leveraging the full gamut
we can tie in resources such as logging
and tracing into these intuitive
dashboards that can give a holistic view
of the application to our development
team we no longer need very specialized
resources that specialize in building
these dashboards or or knowing some
outside tooling that that they can tie
into a pipeline or a CI CD environment
whereas now our developers can get back
to writing code quickly and efficiently
and that's essentially the gamut of what
we use today and we continue to use
things like cloud run to offload some of
our nightly jobs Cron's and
what-have-you so it sounds like adam was
built with a very cloud first
architecture in mind when you were
implementing this were there any things
that you wish were different cloud yeah
so when we first started the product
identity platform wasn't a thing and now
it is ideally we would like to encompass
everything within Google cloud platform
it gives us true visibility we don't
need to go to numerous systems and
applications to see where we stand in
terms of identity it would be ideal if
it was all within one platform which is
what our goal has been so we use octo
today and ideally we'd be leveraging
identity platform well thank you so much
Olek for coming in telling us about how
sada built these solutions in the cloud
thank you thanks for joining us and stay
tuned for more customer interviews on
stack jab
[Music]